le corona virus demeure très mystérieux
mais de plus en plus de recherches le
démontre - les personnes infectées ont
de cinq tombes plus les anticorps ont
tendance à disparaître rapidement
parfois après seulement quelques
semaines ils nous ont observé une
diminution à partir des six semaines
entre mende et à part après six semaines
il ya toujours une activité de l'est
moins important une nouvelle qui ne
surprend pas les médecins les
coronavirus en général c'est pas très
bon pour faire développer des anticorps
qui durent longtemps pour le rhume
ordinaire c maximum un an plus tôt six
mois mais ne plus avoir d'anticorps ne
veut pas dire que le corps est démuni si
l'aco vide frappe une seconde fois
un cas d'infection il ya forcément des
cellules mémoires des mémoires qui ont
été générés qui pourrait réactiver et
monty réponse immunitaire assez
rapidement pour potentiellement contre
les virus
mais c'est tout des choses pour
lesquelles nous n'avons pas encore assez
de recul pour pouvoir y répondre
en revanche il manque encore tellement
d'information sur le virus que même avec
des anti corps dans le système
les chercheurs ne savent pas si les gens
sont vraiment protéger contre une
deuxième et fiction pour le moment avoir
des syndicats ça veut pas nécessairement
dire une immunité ont répété qu'elle ne
pas non plus donc on ne le sait pas bref
en attendant de percer tous les mystères
est possible de savoir si l'immunité
collective peut nous protéger contre les
prochaines vagues est encore trop
d'inconnues à mon avis quand je prends
une positionnement final je pense que si
vous cherchiez à la qualité des tests
qu'on peut avoir
donc moi je pense qu'il est encore trop
tôt pour se positionner sur les éléments
alors à long terme
une chose est sûre si la santé publique
le virus est toujours présent le masque
la distanciation physique et les mesures
d'hygiène demeure donc plus que jamais
nécessaire ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal